joining me now is Molly Hemingway
editor-in-chief of the Federalist and
Fox News contributor and Stephen Miller
former senior advisor to president Trump
and America First legal founder Molly
the left's rules are no recusal ever for
any bias or appearance of a conflict
right the left says that if they have a
spouse that is compromised in some ways
no recusal at all but if anyone who's
conservative who's a Justice or involved
in law enforcement has a spouse that is
politically active well that of course
means that you have to recuse and here
we have a situation where the spouse of
this person you know is a donor is an
activist but even more than that we know
that this person himself was involved in
the IRS scandal he was involved in
Prosecuting the former governor of
Virginia who was widely considered to be
a presidential Contender Prosecuting him
that prosecution that conviction was
overturned by the Supreme Court nine to
nothing I mean this is someone who if
you were trying to make it seem like
this was above board you really could
not have done a worse job in picking
someone and Stephen speaking of Smith
I'm getting some early days of Mueller
Vibes here check this out
say that he's independent he's a
registered political independent we are
told and will work this case without
fear or favor he's not someone who's
going to waste any time hand ringing
over these side shows given his skill
and tenacity and he's known for being
really past and cutting to the chase
okay the turtleneck doesn't help with
the credibility there Stephen wasn't
this really predictable
oh he's so skilled Laura so tenacious
and did did I hear mention that he's
registered as an independent
unbelievable I mean look Laura the
bottom line is the top levels of the
Department of Justice are Democrats we
have seen this over and over again doj
at the career level is run by democrats
they protect each other they watch out
for each other they take care of each
other that's why all the leaks only do
one thing hurt Republicans that's why
all the spin only helps one group
Democrats that's what all the political
prosecutions are targeted in One
Direction at Trump and Republicans
that's why pro-lifers go to jail and
that's why pro-abortion terrorists don't
go to jail we are witnessing the demise
of the rule of law in this country
Molly I think it's so bad on so many
levels and it's a huge mistake for the
Biden administration at a time where
they say we want to return to normal
order uphold institutions Republicans
and conservatives and wacky Mega people
were trying to disrupt the process on
January 6th but they're the great
disruptors because nobody believes that
this guy is going to be without fear or
favor I'm so tired of that phrase too
right it would be a mistake if they were
held accountable by members of of
corporate press but again you know if we
take it back a few years we're talking
about a former president who was
persecuted by the Department of Justice
you had FBI agents falsifying evidence
to secure a wiretap to spy defies a
court campaign you had years of these
politicized leaks you have had you know
just really remarkably horrible behavior
all of the decisions made by Merritt
Garland and by his Department of Justice
throughout this Biden Administration
have been really not appropriate given
that pass that's there there is no
reason why anybody should have any
modicum of trust in what they're doing
and they don't seem to care they're just
flaunting it at this point now I need to
get both of your thoughts on this an
Ohio man who stole Bourbon and a coat
rack during the capital Riot just got
got three years in prison
that's twice as long as that Lefty
lawyer who firebombed NYPD patrol car
with that Molotov cocktail during the
George Floyd Riot Stephen
three years I mean there's no question
that the Department of Justice is being
used to send a message at only one group
of Americans and that is conservatives
we've seen this throughout the January 6
cases but in particular when you compare
that when you compare it to what is
happening with Street criminals in this
country with BLM rioters in this country
with antifa Terrace in this country with
people who try to murder police officers
in this country with the revolving door
of Justice where you can attack and
assault and maim and you can even murder
and you will be set free in this country
there is not and has not been for a long
time a single uniform standard of
Justice which is what we desperately
need now Molly what's been done to some
of these January 6 defendants
pre-trial detention for 20 months
for I know saying what they did was
great but 20 months of pre-trial
detention it's just unbelievable no
Republicans are speaking about this like
Lauren bobert I think and Margaret
Taylor green but very few are even
talking about these poor people and
again this was after 2020 which saw
riots in cities throughout the country
attacks on the White House Federal
courthouses statues and monuments the
Department of Justice was largely
uninterested in Prosecuting any of that
they've spent more money and been more
tenacious in going after these people
you know some of whom like all political
violence is bad some of these people
were let into the capital and
Republicans are scared to talk about it
that is a very bad sign because it's
really important to be honest about
what's going on here about the about the
rule of law and how much is being how
much we have two standards of justice so
it's a very big problem yeah crimes
should be prosecuted but it shouldn't be
disproportionately prosecuted compared
to the violent crime that Steve was just
uh relaying Molly and Stephen wonderful
to see both thank you thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else